basta
[Musica]
renzo vieni qua dentro
byrne in mano come il rambo
[Musica]
se questa deve scomparire dalla mia
monaco un pari non ama l'altro vigente
oggi la magia scarseggia proporzione già
che scompare così e straniere nei nove
ma stamane a milano non è possibile sta
roba
io non ho mai sfruttato uno youtuber per
fare visualizzazione allora capisco
perché questo specchio mi sta dando del
cavallo chiaro mi fa schifo possiamo
dare di sé
[Risate]
da dove cominciare la transizione più
parti pur dio perché siamo ancora pronto
secondo voi
aprea questo abito mi conferisce potrà
imporre andare ciao 6 l'autista di te
stesso ciao va avanti come in gran
turismo
lo vediamo un po cosa succede corse
compagna ma funziona davvero pochi
mangiare bravissimo perché lo regala
questo video non ha nessuno scopo
offensivo o denigratorio
per rivederlo una persona città fila in
cucina immediatamente preparami ben noti
sculaccia manco fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccio cioè noi siamo medici aiuto non
valesse più schifo ciao ragazzi siamo
qua perché io sono
sono ben
niente comunque volevo dirvi cioè la
spranga di ferro usato un'arma sasha mi
chiamarono non vuole parlarci attraverso
questa modalità problemi che insultano
più se averlo affondare voci che
annunciano che è successo
magari non riesce a incanalarsi con una
piastra e l'azienda non fatemi inchioda
può dire una cosa tu sei il più famoso
d'italia si sono un grande esperto di
trucchi e di cose che che si riescono a
fare quindi fidget finnair
[Musica]
[Applauso]
davide
si no
[Musica]
quasi meritiamo questi screzi belle
tutti ragazzi sono a gara di raimo e se
non vi insieme a fuochi j
ci vediamo tecnici schietti utili
[Musica]
bentornato come cazzo entrare in casa
mia
raga è tornato non è possibile
e allora [ __ ] se ti dico figlio di
[ __ ] fatti vedere vasta fatti vedere
mica ti ammazzo ma cosa salta cos'è sono
più apprezzabile come donna da maschio
che diede vita a don 3 2 1 che madonna e
di sinistra senti io chiudo così perché
paga gli iscritti devono essere violento
che più per restringe alla violenza che
faccio così picchiando la webcam in
stringimi il video youtube
ma cos'è mangiato
[Musica]
cosa sto vedendo regalo cos'è sta roba
da lorenzo faccio vedere il tuo sguardo
seducente per conquistare le ragazze
adesso il video
bello e fu così che siano le di favini
scese a 13 iscritti è una cosa che l'ha
detto sul serio
scusami se ti ho fatto così
era un complimento
[Musica]
si dice sempre ogni tanto che i pulsanti
e dirle puoi vedere se non rendi
stickers nessun odore
voglio però sempre bello questo viene
anche alto compleanno sistema non è come
sembra e un video e non voglio farlo che
portassi che mi stanno tutti andando
dalla direzione opposta quindi oggi e
godzilla
ahia ahia è bruttissimo la scotta pure
negozi destra
beh lì non sarà la cosa più brutta che
abbia mai fatto
sacco di merda busta di chris non vali
niente fai schifo è veramente parla con
l'anonimo perché se avessi le palle ci
incontrassimo cir con grossi buchi con
dragon dragon ora in ora
chi incontra piccoli ci incontra ha
detto uscite saluta marco tennis e
camera
[Musica]
[Applauso]
una bravata di però slittare le dita
[Musica]
effetti speciali is ok perfetto e grazie
a dio cosa ho visto cos'è sto schifo ma
che che cosa grande cazzo è sta mentendo
ammontare questo video che sono credente
è stata lei l'avete vista tutti tutti
l'avete vista è colpa sua
sempre casino fai sempre casino è laggiù
striscia la mia energia quale i beni che
viaggio in quarant'anni a ragazzi noi
stiamo provando la da nintendo switch
che è una che ti giochi che ti tra le
modeste un po più bassa un po di più
ok per assalta tre volte
complimenti puoi andare a narnia
[Musica]